I suppose every war,
the short ones and long ones,
the ones that get televised
and the ones that don't,
the ones where we get to see the
coffins and the ones where we don't
have their romance and their reality,
it seems to be an endless in the face
of whatever modernization of war,
media coverage of war,
the devastating critique of wars and
individual human experience by so many
great poets and writers
for a century and a half.
It doesn't seem to matter what
changes or what happens,
but youth grow up to be excited about war.
Ambrose Bierce once wrote that only,
I quote him,
only fools forget the causes of war,
but then it's the same.
Ambrose Bierce one of the most,
certainly I think the unique
American writer about the
civil war in so many ways.
A kind of bitter,
brutal realists too,
was wounded three times in the war,
hit in the head with a shell shot from
a cannon should have died Carston and
part of his skull,
which may explain Ambrose Bierce actually,
but as beers who also wrote that lovely
little line where he said the soil of
pieces thickly sown the seeds of war.
Yeah.
Too much peace for a while
and people get anxious.
Americans win this war broke out
and braced it with a fever that is,
uh, an enthusiasm and an almost, um,
undefinable joy.
Uh,
that may be a little tough to
understand today or appreciate.
It's only in the wake of war or in
the face of real war. Of course,
the people get reflective at the
end of it all at the end of it all.
And Lincoln's second inaugural
is this famous passage.
And by the way,
there may be more book titles drawn from
this one page and a half speech than
any other piece of prose ever
Penn by an American. I mean,
I can just start ticking off the
book titles that come out of phrases.
The latest is a Jim Mcpherson,
his latest book of essays called
this mighty scourge of war.
At some point we will run out.
It's only a page and a half.
I'm after all on the occasion
corresponding to this four years ago,
this is Lincoln,
March,
1865 remembering March,
all thoughts were anxiously
directed to an impending civil war.
All dreaded it all sought to avert it.
Well,
the inaugural address was being delivered
from this place devoted all together
to saving the union without,
or hmm.
Insurgent agents were in the city
seeking to destroy it without war.
Okay.
Seeking to dissolve the Union and
divide effects by negotiation.
Both parties deprecated war,
but one of them would make war rather
than let the nation survive and the other
would accept war rather
than let it parish.
And the war came.
Well,
now that's Lincoln's argument,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Once I would make war,
no,
the other side would except war.
Okay.
We're going to revisit that
moment in just a minute. Lincoln,
so called April policy of April,
1861.
His maneuvers against Jefferson Davis
maneuvers about the single fort in
Charleston harbor or the civil
war would actually begin.
Did Lincoln maneuver the
south end of the first shot?
Always been a question
on answered. Um, quickly,
let me revisit with
you. Um, whoops, sorry.
Um, this question of causation. I
left that in a bit of a bay. It's, uh,
there was,
uh,
there was a school of interpretation
of this war that has had a tiny,
tiny little revival of lake,
uh,
in the hands of greatest stories. People
I greatly admire, like Edward Errors.
And you've read two of his essays for
this week, worrying about the civil war.
Um, and, uh,
my colleague here skip
scout in a different way.
There's been a kind of a little revival
of this notion that the civil war
might've been preventable,
that it might've been needless.
Um,
no one is arguing that as,
as vigorously as James G.
Randall and Avery craven and our host of
other American historians do it in the
1920s, thirties and
forties, up to World War II.
World War Two is going to really reshape
that interpretation and put it on the
run.
But I wanted to just visit it a moment
because it shows us not only the
historical interpretations as will be
yours are influenced by one's own times,
one's own experiences,
one's own assumptions,
one's on sentiments and
how the world shapes us.
Sometimes it comes out of conviction.
The needless wars school interpretation
was led by James Round on every craven
and Avery Cravens.
Casey was a Quaker,
but these were men deeply influenced by
the outer disillusionment of World War
One.
They came of age and cut their teeth
on history at a time when the world had
collapsed into what seemed to be in
the end. And explicable meaningless war
is that unforgettable scene
at the very beginning of, um,
the guns of August by Barbara Tuchman.
No one reads her anymore.
She was at one point the most
popular historian in America,
um, turn it over the Middle
Ages. She wrote about world war.
She wrote up all kinds of things.
Anyway,
at the very opening of the guns of August,
there's a scene,
we're on a German general
meets of French general,
somewhere in the mid or late 1920.
And the one general says
to the other, uh, sir,
why did it happen?
And you're the general says,
I don't know.
I really don't know.
In the wake of the Bay of Pigs and
before the Cuban missile crisis,
President John Kennedy gave a copy of
the guns of August and ordered every
member of his National Security
Council in his cabinet to read it.
And he quoted that passage and he said,
never will.
We never,
shall we be caught having to
answer that question about war.
I don't know,
in that kind of disillusionment
and interpretation that fines,
sheer politics and fanaticism and uh,
you know,
uh,
aggressive emotionalism
and overblown kind of, uh,
what did Randall call it?
Anxious fury as the essential explanation
of why the war came in 1861 can make a
certain sense. There's a bug
geiling quality of that argument.
When we look at the folly of human
history and the folly of human nature
at all changed in so many ways.
In the wake of the Second World War,
a war that was all about it,
he ology all about racism,
all about the survival of enlightenment,
ideas against [inaudible],
against fasteners,
fascism and so on and so on.
And the generation led by such as storage
is Arthur Schlesinger Jr and many,
many,
many others came to see the American civil
wars coming when they started writing
in the 1950s and sixties and into the
70s as what they would call and your
repressible conflict and
this array of arguments,
they all get kind of all
lumped under this heading.
Irrepressible conflict thesis began
to flow from American historian Don
Fehrenbach or may have captured that
interpretation best in a line when he said
the civil war came and it was fought.
MMM.
To bring,
well,
how did he put it to bring to bring
great national progress at great national
cost. I remember mind entirely
comfortable with that idea.
You know? Well, it all had to happen.
It was bloody and horrible and
terrible and all those people died.
But we all got better for
it. That never, never,
never sits very well with me,
especially when you study the
memory of the war and the aftermath.
But what happened in post war, World War
II scholarship, and it's still there,
it's still at the heart of how we try
to explain this most pivotal event.
The one of the most pivotal events in
American history is a certain respect for
moral questions,
a certain respect for ideas and in a,
and the,
and the notion that politics
sometimes about something,
oh,
that's a
utterly horribly streamlined way of
saying you don't find many historians
anymore who argue from a
needless war perspective.
Although what you do find is a kind of
roller coaster ride through American
scholarship about this,
the civil war,
sometimes deeply influenced by Vietnam,
sometimes deeply influenced.
Even today,
some have argued about Harry Stack,
uh,
skip stouts book. Um, if
you know professor stout,
he is remarkable new book out about
whether the American civil war was a just
war.
And I will revisit that question at the
end near the end of this course and use
a couple of his arguments.
It's controversial in your book.
It's an interesting book.
It's a question we've never
truly asked about this good war.
Was it just,
does it fit?
Does it fulfill the principles
of just war doctrine?
Can it,
does it matter?
Okay.
All right.
Um,
but back to April,
whether it was just
and just why it became so
bloody and so prolonged,
we're going to take up over and over,
but it surely did happen
and it began,
I dunno if that map works terribly well.
Probably doesn't.
It's the best I can do this morning
is a map of Charleston harbor,
which had their last remaining federal
installation fort around the coast of the
American south,
still in federal hands.
By march and April of 1861
the seven states of the seceded south,
the deep South had begun
to cs coastal forts.
They began to see these federal arsenals.
They seized post offices and
they seized federal courts.
Now,
I can guarantee you today if you
seized a federal court office building,
and if, particularly if you
killed anybody in the act
or if you took over the US post office,
uh,
I know nobody cares about post dogs is
because you do everything online. I mean,
it was putting those people down there
on, on, uh, on elm street. You mean?
No such sweet people that if somebody's
taken over that post office at gunpoint
is, is not, not a thought.
But if you did that today, I,
and you'd be in federal prison and no time
and you could be charged with treason.
Now we can come back to that issue
of treason when the course ends, uh,
revisited if you want, um, about this war.
But by and large, every federal
installation in a seceded state,
the seven seceding states had
been seized by those states.
Confederate states except Fort Sumpter.
Okay.
And it was a brand new forte.
MMM.
Oh God.
It can't be more than 200,
maybe 300 yards across diameter.
It had just been built in the late 1850s
is part of the coastal fort system,
a big, huge high stone
walls, but 20 feet high.
It sits out at the mouth
of Charleston harbor.
Here it is nearly a mile from fort Sumpter
to the tip of the town of Charleston,
which is here from the battery park and
Charleston to the fort is nearly a mile.
You can almost not see it.
Um,
there is today a monument.
I wish I had a slide of it to show you.
It's one of my favorite for strange
reasons. Civil war monuments,
the thousands upon thousands
of civil war monuments.
Many of them are so generic
you don't even notice them.
This one you notice it's right at the
tip of battery park in Charleston where
they used to hang pirates.
It looks right out at Fort Sumpter.
It was put up in the early 20th century.
It's a confederate monument
of our wing Roman soldier.
I think Roman,
because of the helmet I'm told is Roman.
He's some combination of of a
winged creature and a soldier.
He's about four times the size of life
he is looking out at Fort Sumpter.
And the inscription around the bottom says
to the defenders of Charleston,
quote,
count them happy.
Who for their faith and
courage endured a great fight.
I'm gonna repeat that.
Count them happy.
Who for their faith and
courage endured a great fight
on our monuments of this war.
Almost all of them,
you will find almost nothing
about what caused the war or even
about what its consequences were.
Almost all it was just a great fight.
Okay.
And the dead are happy.
Well, what to do about fort Sumpter. Uh,
in his first inaugural of March four,
1861,
Lincoln promised, he said,
promised to quote, hold,
occupy and possess
remaining federal property.
Now think about it.
If Lincoln and the Republicans are going
to make a stand against the session,
and once he finally comes into office,
by the way, the day he entered off,
as all at federal property had
been taken by those seven states,
it's already done.
He inherits the situation.
Now he could have backed away and
continued to try to negotiate.
And there was a compromise
negotiation under John Jay Crittendon,
a Kentucky senator,
Washington for a while going on in
late February and it never came up with
anything new.
They were going to try again,
a geographic boundary out
in the west with slavery,
although don't forget the dred Scott
decision declared that on leads illegal,
um,
they're going to try to,
or the rub up something again about
fugitive slaves to satisfy the south.
They just couldn't come it.
Any new ideas and Lincoln could have tried
to continue to whole compromise Nikos
negotiation conventions he could have
or he could have held firm to the
Republican position.
That's the session was
illegal and impossible and
unconstitutional and had to be
stumped.
But if he lets fort Sumpter go,
there was a garrison there led by a,
um,
a colonel named Anderson.
Yeah.
He just lets it go and effect.
He's saying,
well maybe all that seizure
federal properties legitimate, um,
maybe it's a session is possible.
Right.
It was about the only place he could have
taken a stand if he was going to take
a stand
on Lincoln was buying time and he took
a whole month of time before he acted.
Yeah,
he was hoping for what he
called privately quote,
voluntary reconstruction.
He was hoping for Saner minds
in the south to some, you know,
a union spirit in the south to somehow
take whole and as much been said over the
years about Lincoln overestimating
union sentiment across the south,
he may have indeed over
estimate at union sentiment,
but there was a good deal of it.
There were a lot of frightened people and
the upstate counties of Virginia and a
Western Virginia and in western North
Carolina and eastern Tennessee and
northern Georgia.
Those Union is pockets of the south were
scared about this because they have to
make terrible decisions. Now, if
this cozy, if this goes to war,
who do they go with and stay home?
Well, colonel, I'm sorry, Major
Robert Anderson had about 80 men.
He was from Kentucky. That's from
slave holding in his background,
but
he'll never end up with the south.
A commissioners from South Carolina.
Okay.
Had come to Washington as early as January
of [inaudible] 61 to negotiate that
specific forts release.
They wanted it.
Federal government had basically
stonewalled president of Buchanan.
Then the lame duck president tried
actually to reinforce the fort and by
reinforce it for,
I mean send food to the garrison of
um,
between January five and nine of 1861,
Buchanan the only act Buchanan
even tried to make about secession.
He was begging to get out of office.
Buchanan send a ship called the star of
the west full of supplies down the coast
of Fort Sumpter to feed the men shore
batteries around the harbor actually
opened up fire and one had
a direct hit on the ship,
but nothing came of it. No,
it's January five to nine.
South Carolina was the only succeeded
state wasn't until the 11th that
Mississippi went and then Georgia and
then about six others in the next three
weeks.
Lincoln's April policy if you like,
was a process of trying to buy time
and if there was to be war or firing or
shooting about Fort Sumpter,
he was trying to make sure the
shots were fired by the south.
Now there were Harkes
and his administration,
there were Harkson the Republican
party who wanted him to act faster.
One of them wrote to Lincoln privately
and said, quote, give up Sumpter, sir,
and you are as dead politically is.
John Brown is physically
yeah.
Newspapers across the north strongly
republican newspaper started to print
headlines like,
do we have a government wanted a policy
or come to the point Mr Lincoln and so on.
People were ready now do something.
Now his secretary of state duly
appointed in great part of this,
Doris Kearns Goodwin is shown and argued
in a recent bestselling book team of
rivals was boy, he makes Seward,
Lincoln's principal rival for the, uh,
the nomination of the Republican Party.
My not only put a few of his enemies in
his own cabinet to control them and use
them politically in the end,
made an absolute best friend
out of William Seward.
But not yet.
Seward was a dove on this.
Seward wanted to negotiate.
He urged evacuation of
the fort and then he said,
leave the door open to
voluntary reconstruction as
it might take hold around the
south as southerners might see that this
new Lincoln administration was willing
to talk.
Yeah,
and it isn't.
All the sewer did.
Seward launched a crazy plan to declare
war on Spain and France to direct
America's attention outward to the world
and therefore cause national unity wag
the dog. All right, you see the movie?
Let's just go to war with Spain and
France and all those crazy southern is
realize, oh, the nation is at risk.
Lincoln immediately rejected this idea,
although unfortunately it got out
there and the foreign ministers, Spain,
France needed explanations.
Thank you very much.
Stuart also made private promises as
secretary of state to southerners that
Sumpter would ultimately be evacuated.
Just hang in there. Just wait.
Well,
Lincoln found that out.
He said the Seward in effect shut up.
Now,
Lincoln tried in his approach to Sumpter
two separate reinforcement of these
troops and military act from provisions
and Humanitarian Act and he wanted to
stress the ladder.
He notified finally southern officials,
you never forget them as the confederate
government just notified South
Carolina.
He said that he was going to send food
and provisions to Hungary soldiers.
Now who could be against that.
You just got to feed some people.
He called it a mission of
humanity, bringing food to
a hungry man, quote unquote.
But the confederate leadership took,
this is a direct challenge and Lincoln
did indeed send a ship down the coast
about the eighth or ninth of
ape known sixth or 7th of April,
uh,
any 61 and the prolonged
suspense finally came to an end
that one ship was provisioned with food.
Now the truth is there were some arms
and some weapons and the whole as well,
and the end isn't going to matter a lot.
The confederate cabinet met
under Jefferson Davis and
the 9th of April and they
made a decision that if Blinken tried to
sail that ship into Charleston harbor,
they would fire on it.
On the 11th of April,
Major Anderson in the fort was going to
chance to surrender by the authorities
in Charleston.
He refused.
And at four 30 in the morning, in
the dark of night, April 12th, 1861,
about 100 cannon from all
around Charleston Harbor,
100 federal Canon's originally now seized
by the confederate states of America,
opened up m bombarded.
Charleston bombarded Fort
Sumpter for 35 hours.
Yeah.
Anderson's men hid
underground and dug out.
They'd been well prepared for this
and none of them died. And the
of thousands of shells
lobbed into the Ford.
The relief expedition arrived out of the
mouth of the harbor during the firing
and it never got to the fort.
On the 14th of April,
after the bombardment ended,
Anderson was forced to surrender the
fort to take down the United States flag,
a brand new confederate states flag
with stars and bars was put up.
And then Anderson's men
held, uh, a gun salute.
21 gun salute.
And the first casualties of
the war occurred when two
of Anderson's troops were
killed on a powder keg blew up because
it was too close to one of the muskets
for April's later 620,000 dead
and the 1.2 million wounded
before I go go back up at Fort Sumpter.
Okay.
On April 14th,
it will be attended by William Lloyd
garrison and 3000 freed people.
Okay.
But that's a long way away.
Yeah.
The day after the firing on Fort
Sumpter all across the country,
the headline was war
and Lincoln
sent an executive order dot declaring war.
Lincoln's position on this was clear.
He to him anyway,
that no nation can declare war on itself.
He never accepted succession as legal
or constitutional or appropriate,
but he called for 75,000 volunteers
to put down a domestic insurrection.
And in the constitution,
the President United States is given
control over the military to put down
domestic insurrection.
He called it a rebellion.
No.
The most immediate and the most important
immediate result of the firing on Fort
Sumpter, of course, was the
succession of the upper south
part of the upper south.
Where's my map?
Well,
oh, I apologize. I should have had that
map, right. Well, you'll remember the map
for more southern states.
Slave states will succeed in the wake
of something to the most pivotal course
was Virginia.
But Note Virginia had held a secession
convention back in February and
decisively voted against the session
after Fort Sumpter in this state of war,
hysteria and fever and fear,
and under.
Now this new argument that what the
Lincoln Administration had really done was
an act of coercion against
the south coercion. Now,
the feeding of some 80 soldiers in the
fort was being interpreted as coercion.
Okay,
but Virginia quickly,
overnight held a new secession convention,
actually had state legislature
held it and it voted 88 to 55
devote 88 to 55 lots of those,
no votes, almost all of those no votes
coming from the western part of Virginia.
West Virginia didn't exist yet.
The western part of Virginia where there
was very little slavery and some of the
upper counties of Virginia.
April 17th only three days after
the surrender of Fort Sumpter,
Virginia seceded from the union by may
six Arkansas seceded by a vote of 69 to
one in secession convention,
North Carolina on May 20th
voted to send the look.
We're North Carolina is now,
it's between Virginia and South Carolina.
What are they gonna do?
They voted unanimously in convention
just to seed and finally on June 8th by a
two to one vote of a popular referendum.
These we've done different
ways in different states
on in a popular referendum,
Tennessee in a two to one vote,
approximately
seceded from the union or
the confederacy was now 11 states.
It would never really
be any more than that,
but there was great tension
about what Maryland, Delaware,
Kentucky,
and Missouri would actually do.
Lincoln is reported to have said that
he hoped to have God on his side,
but he was certain he wanted Kentucky.
Now there's been a whole flurry of
emails recently on the slavery in history
network of historians online.
I'm trying to trace that quote just in
the past couple of weeks and the truth is
nobody can actually find it anywhere.
It's one of those many, many,
many probably Apocryphal Lincoln quotes.
He must probably said
something like it's somewhere,
but I just couldn't resist using it.
I've used it for so many years,
so footnote might be apocryphal.
Okay.
He did need Kentucky and whatever.
He said,
all those states were deeply divided
about what to do and what they will do in
the war will prove that and they will
be terrible, horrible places to be
geographically, emotionally,
physically. In the war.
Maryland was horribly divided.
Node where it is,
it's right above Washington DC,
approximately 50,000 white men fought
for the union in Maryland and the civil
war, approximately, I'm sorry,
about 50,000 white men in
Maryland fought in the civil war,
30,000 on the Union side,
20,000 on the confederate side.
And of those 30,000 on the union side,
9,000 of them were African Americans.
Kentucky
had about 50,000 men fight for the union,
and about 35,000 men fight for
the confederacy. And per capita,
Kentucky,
uh,
produced more African American soldiers
for the Union army than any other state.
24,000 total.
Yeah,
Missouri. The numbers are
even greater. In Missouri,
about 80,000 men fought for the union,
about 30,000 fought for the confederacy,
and there were about 3000
to one on either side.
They were gorillas looking
for the best pay day.
Okay.
Early versions of Jesse
James Without ideology later.
Jesse James got real ideology though.
That's another story.
And folks, especially in those
states, this was immediately,
you've heard all the cliches about how
it was a fratricidal conflict kind of
brothers war immediately.
It was a brother's war and thousands of
families in April and May and June of
1861,
brothers and fathers looked each other
in the eye and had to decide what they
would do.
Okay.
Henry Clay had seven
grandsons in Kentucky.
Three fought for the union and
for fought for the confederacy.
Okay.
John Jay Crittendon of Kentucky,
of these as a senator of the Crittendon
compromise efforts in this position.
Winter had one son who became a general
in the union army and one son who became
a general in the confederate army.
Both survived and I've always wanted to
know about Crittendon family reunions,
but I've never looked into it.
Mrs Lincoln,
Mary Todd Lincoln, who was of
course born and raised in Kentucky,
I had four brothers who all fought for
the confederacy and three brothers in law
who fought for the confederacy.
Okay.
It will lead late at all kinds of charges.
Well,
some charges about treason
against her and so on.
Le Sympathies for the south and so on.
And so
John See Pemberton from Pennsylvania
became a confederate general and was
ultimately the general who surrendered
Vicksburg to grant in 1863 George Thomas
was Virginia born
old slave holding family,
but he never resigned his commission
and he became known as the rocker
Chickamauga. The union general who won
the battle of chicken was a Virginian
and the stories go on and on and on.
There's the story of Clifton
and William Prentice.
One of them fought in the sixth
Marilyn Infantry, uh, union regimen.
The other fought in the second Marilyn
Infantry, a confederate regiment.
Both were wounded at Petersburg
on April two on the same day,
1865 and the last week of the war.
And they died and cots right next
to each other in a field hospital.
Okay.
And the list goes on and on.
No.
When people went to war in 1861,
what did they say they were doing?
What did they say? Where their aims
were there? What were their reasons?
We have,
uh,
thousands of diary entries and letters
and editorial and all sorts of things to
draw upon.
But on the northern side,
what you find that summer is not only
the sense that this will be a short war,
and that's a preface worth
pointing out.
But people would say over and over,
they were fighting for the flag,
but they were fighting for the union.
They were fighting for the constitution.
They were fighting to save the republic.
They were fighting two quotes,
save the government and you keep
hearing those phrases and you,
you keep thinking, oh man, these are
abstractions. What were they really doing?
You keep reading and You keep hearing
them say the same damn thing. Well,
there's a lot of good scholarship on
this now that shows us that in 1860
[inaudible] in America, the u s
constitution was important to people.
They saw it as a kind of protection.
They saw it as a source of social order.
They saw the American nation as now
something they were directly experiencing.
Millions were directly experiencing
the government as never before in those
debates of the 1850s and as I've said
before now voter turnout just zoomed in
the 1850 to 75 and 80% in each
general election from 852 on
a pallet and then a
marvelous book about this.
They said that the constitution and the
government for so many northerners was
like a shield of protection and the
southern succession now was not just a
threat to this government.
It was a threat to social order itself
and are therefore had to be stopped.
Okay.
Uh, New Hampshire farmer who became
a buck private in 1861 said, quote,
the question now is country or
no country liberty or slavery
is a beautiful clarity
to that isn't there?
Now I don't know what he said after
bull runner after Antietam or after
Spotsylvania,
if he survived a 50 year old railroad
contractor named Robert mcallister threw
down his lucrative job in
1861 and enlisted at age 50
quote to help us put down
this wicked and unjustifiable rebellion.
Our country and property is
worth nothing if we don't,
nor will life be secure.
Okay.
This is all over people's letters.
They said they were fighting for liberty
of course.
So Soda Southern,
no. Another argument here, and again,
Phil Pallen and has made this better than
anyone I think is he's argued that sun
is a northern, is it sort of come
to view the U s constitution? This,
you know this document we live under Dan,
different ways that northerners that
come to see the constitution as a kind of
protector, much violated
now by Kansas, Nebraska Act,
dred Scott decision,
et cetera.
Whereas southerners had come to see
that constitution more as a destroyer,
as something to fear.
It might if the wrong
people get hold of it,
begin to attack or erode their society.
There were a lot of people,
particularly in the north,
but then quickly in the south as well,
who when this war broke out began to
see it in terms of cosmic dualism,
good and evil.
God was entering history right away.
Christian America began to
interpret this in millennial terms.
God had a quarrel in America.
People start arguing and they're going
to really be arguing this after the
enormous bloodshed of 62 and 63 when
they have to try to explain why this is
happening.
Okay?
They're going to say,
God has an appointment with America
and he's going to decide whose sins are
worse.
Now on the southern side, as I said,
people have to make tough choices,
horrible choices.
Who Do they go with and join their
neighbors or pose their neighbor
Mary Chestnut.
The great dire is from South Carolina who
indeed kept the most famous diary by a
southern woman.
There are many of them.
Okay.
She remembered March and April,
1861 this way and here we have
another kind of beautiful clarity.
Okay,
we separated,
said Mary Chestnut because of in Kampala,
in compatibility of temper.
We are divorced north from south
because we hate each other so much.
Okay, Mary, I get it. Doors,
papers you hate us.
Walter knew Jenna,
Mississippi lawyer who did not own slaves,
nevertheless declared in 1861
there without slave labor.
Now the non slave holders arguing this,
that without slave labor the country
would be quoted in his words,
a barren waste and desolate plane.
We can only live in exists by this
species of labor and hence I am willing to
continue the fight to the last,
well Nugen hadn't seen any fight yet,
but
nevermind.
Well in the end,
the south from the highest ranks of
Jefferson Davis on down to buck private's
are all going to say they were
fighting for their liberty.
Everybody was fighting for their liberty
and what blocks to get into
this thing and 62 and 63, uh,
they're fighting for their liberty too.
Yeah,
everybody is.
Lincoln later said,
everybody declared for liberty.
Okay,
no, I'm making a mistake. I love to cook.
My friend Uriah over there on the stone
wall and Woolsey a walk every time,
every morning on the
way over here to class,
I'd go by and I rub my finger on his name
for, I dunno, good luck or something.
If I teach her long enough,
it's probably going to wear off.
But everybody in the union army, it
wasn't a Uriah parmelee. In fact,
the vast majority were not going
to free the slaves just yet.
There's a story of a
Yankee soldier in Virginia in 1861
oh encounters a slave woman in it.
And he's taken that woman's goods and
that woman's, well, wait a minute,
aren't you coming here
to help us? And, uh,
he answered her and said,
MMM,
no. He answered her and
said, no. The woman says,
we were told you are coming here to
help us and instead you steal from us.
And the soldier replied,
you're a Goddamn liar.
I'm fighting for $14 a month.
And the union,
there's a beautiful clarity in that too.
I ain't ain't here to free you.
Oh, I got behind on this
outline, didn't I? That's okay.
That's actually just fine.
MMM.
When we resumed that don't, don't leave
yet. When we resumed next Tuesday,
I will talk a little bit about west
point and what happened at West Point on
union and confederate or southern
and northern men began to leave.
And then we'll begin the war and we'll
talk about comparative strengths and so
on.
But let me leave you for today
and the weekend if you don't mind.
With Walt Whitman,
again,
Whitman's opening poem of his immortal
collection called drum taps in a kind of
agonizing way,
may have captured what was in the
heads of most Americans in 1861
to the drum taps prompt.
He writes,
the young men falling in
and arming the mechanics,
arming the troll,
the Jack plane,
the blacksmith's hammer tossed
aside with precipitation.
The blood of the city is up armed arm.
The cry everywhere.
The flags flying out from the steeples
of churches and from all the public
buildings and stores, the tearful
parting, the mother kisses or Sun,
the sun kisses the mother low. This
is the mother to part, yet not a word.
Does she speak to detain him?
War and armed races advancing
the welcome for battle.
No turning away now.
War be it weeks,
months or years and armed race
is advancing and it welcomes it.